les médias n'ont donc parlé que de ça la
présence de policiers sur notre plateau
vendredi pour parler de la braven dans
un instant Laurent Nunez préfet de
police de Paris gagnant noir mais je
voudrais vous raconter d'abord dans tous
les week-end avant qu'il arrive parce
que comment il est venu pourquoi il est
venu et cetera cette fameuse brigade
donc la braven qui fait polémique alors
tout le monde que tout le monde sait
alors que tout le monde s'est demandé
qui était vraiment c'est policiers alors
que certains ont porté très rapidement
des accusations mensongères et que la
préfecture a annoncé ouvrir une enquête
administrative et saisir le procureur de
la République le prophète de police de
Paris Laurent du nez et dans TPMP on va
revenir avec lui sur toute l'histoire de
la Braden il va nous expliquer ce qu'est
la braven voilà et il va nous dire ce
qui se passe aussi sur les
manifestations etc mais pour le moment
je récompense à la mise au point et on
va revenir sur cette séquence de
vendredi soir donc tout le monde a parlé
le témoignage de ces quatre policiers
membres de la braven et des unités
spéciales donc il y avait des membres de
la bravème et des unités spéciales
venues cagouler sur le plateau pour
protéger leur anonymat la voie modifiée
le brassard au bras ils sont inexpliquer
leur quotidien et leur de travail lors
des manifestations qui parfois sont
difficiles à encadrer et qui dérape
alors juste après l'émission moi alors
j'étais tranquillement chez moi en train
de manger des bananes spécialité
tunisienne bon et moi voilà moi je m'en
fous total donc je reçois des trucs oui
on nous a accusés d'avoir reçu des
charlatons certains même vous ont accusé
d'avoir engagé des comédiens pour cette
séquence pour dire les mecs sont allés
très loin ça fait réagir jusqu'au plus
haut sommet de l'État et on va vous
raconter tout ce qui s'est passé
chronologiquement pour tout comprendre
20h48
alors là il est 20h43 mais là c'était à
20h40
TPMP précise à l'antenne que les
policiers n'étaient pas tous de la
Bravet même moi je croyais qu'ils
étaient les quatre de la braver vous
savez moi voilà je suis pas les mec de
quotidien je n'arrive pas à 15h pour
faire des répètes j'arrive ici je prends
l'antenne à 18h40 à 18h35 je suis encore
en train de jouer au paddle à 18h38 à
18h38 à 18h39 je vois ce qu'il y a dans
l'émission donc forcément bon j'ai pas
le temps non plus voilà moi je viens ici
en kiffe je suis un pas ici c'est pas
voilà c'est pas non plus c'est pas c'est
pas le bail ici pour moi ici je viens
c'est ma récré de la journée les
emmerdes c'est l'après-midi et le kiffe
c'est le soir dans TPMP donc bon je vois
des gars qui arrivent cagoulé pour moi
il me dit c'est de la bradème après donc
je dis que c'est d'avoir et le mec il me
fait tout de suite la mise au point et
dit non on n'est pas tous de la braven
mais il y en a de la braven mais on peut
pas dire qui c'est parce que sinon voilà
ça peut poser problème mais sachez et
c'est sûr et certain il y avait bien un
membre de la Braden dans ces quatre
personnes qu'on a bien sûr identifié
mais on peut pas vous donner forcément
les noms de ces trois autres personnes
il y en a un qui s'est identifié tout
seul voilà un des policiers que c'est
identifié tout seul mais les trois
autres on peut pas vous donner bien
entendu leur identité pour des raisons
bien sûr de sécurité regardez ce qu'il a
dit
nous des membres de la brevette et des
membres des unités spécialisées qui
interviennent sur le maintien de l'ordre
et on a fait ça toute notre carrière
pendant 15 ans et on a parmi vous qui
ont qui sont entrés dans la ce qu'on
appelle la bravène c'est ça
et nous on fait partie des anciens et
donc on l'a pratiqué de A à Z
mon téléphone 22h27 une heure après la
fin de l'émission Le Syndicat des
commissaires de la police nationale
poste un tweet qui va enflammer Twitter
il réclame des poursuites contre nous
car ils sont persuadés que ce snow pas
des vrais policiers qui ont témoigné sur
notre plateau monsieur d'après nos
informations ce ne sont pas ou plus des
policiers et vous n'avez pas procédé
vous vérifications nécessaires pour
éviter de faire parler ces guignols
usurpateurs vous méritez des poursuites
bon voilà donc c'est ce qu'il dit voilà
après ils ont fini ils ont mis des
tweets bon le problème c'est que non non
les quatre c'est bien des policiers on a
juste un qui a été limite ses fonctions
mais qui était sur le terrain donc son
témoignage était extrêmement important
pour
tout va très vite une heure plus tard la
préfecture de police de Paris annonce
aussi sur Twitter ouvrir une enquête
administrative pour savoir qui sont les
individus venus témoigner sur notre
plateau les premiers éléments notre
procession laissent sa pensée que ces
personnes n'appartiennent pas à la
Bravet en tout état de cause la
préfecture de police ou une enquête
administrative et saisie le procureur la
procureur de la République de Paris donc
bon ça normal mais bon après je vous dis
non on a dit c'est des mecs qui font des
interventions sur le terrain et des
membres de la bradème il y avait un
membre de la voie même où on pouvait pas
apparemment donner le nombre de
personnes qui étaient de la braven
puisque ils ne peuvent pas être
identifiés c'est pour ça qu'ils étaient
cagoulés et bien entendu on a souvent
des policiers qui viennent cagouler ici
on en a eu plein que ce soit sur BTP ou
sur TPMP samedi donc forcément donc ils
ont vu des tweets et il y a tous les
génies
j'ai envie de dire les génies de la
presse les génies de l'audiovisuel qui
s'en sont donnés à cœur joie et moi je
me régalais puisque j'avais chez moi
tranquillement les quatre cartes de
police des quatre intervenants donc je
voyais tout le monde s'agiter moi je
suis en train de jouer au poker avec les
cartes
des amis et donc je voyais tous les
gugusses en train de s'enflammer donc
voilà alors moi il m'appelle plus parce
qu'ils savent comment ils vont être
reçus donc ils appellent souvent Lionel
Stan le directeur général d'ailleurs il
est directeur général et c'est tellement
dégueux sur les articles il appelait
rédacteur en chef de TPMP pour vous dire
ils sont toujours au courant de tout ils
sont toujours à la pointe de
l'information donc samedi beaucoup de
journalistes se sont donnés ils ont
écrit de nombreux articles on dit tiens
là on a peut-être un truc avec des
titres souvent à couleur racoleurs et
racouleurs aussi d'ailleurs et pas
objectif vous allez voir ça dans un
instant mais les chaînes info aussi moi
j'ai jamais été aussi dans des chaînes
info on a aussi parlé alors je voudrais
dire un truc les chéris avant de vous
montrer tout ça
pas mal de me disent ouais pas mal de
gens parfois ils me disent ouais tu as
vu le bad buzz etc c'est ça je vais vous
dire c'est pas parce que des
journalistes parlent d'un truc et
écrivent alors façon ce qui s'est passé
ou ce qui a pu se passer que c'est un
bad buzz je vous le dis pour moi il n'y
a pas de bad buzz dans l'émission et là
alors encore moins que d'habitude nous
on prend des gens ici qui viennent
témoigner on fait tout il y a souvent
des jalousies les gens sont jaloux parce
qu'ils avaient pas eu aussi d'un mec de
la bradème sur le plateau à chaque fois
les mecs se disent comment Hanouna fait
sachez comment j'ai eu le manque de la
Bravet moi je vous dis aussi c'est que
j'ai voilà j'ai des contacts autant chez
les personnes
voilà qui sont de l'autre côté que chez
les personnes qui sont chez les
policiers qui sont parfois des amis que
ce soit du côté comme on dit des voyous
ou du côté de l'autre côté donc c'est
par relation entre ça qu'ils sont venus
donc je pense pas que Yann Barthès qui
est un peu le seum ou Julien belvert
j'ai vu qu'il avait le seum là dans sa
chronique la surcrotinie aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on a pas les mêmes
fréquentations donc forcément eux quand
ils vont recevoir Vladimir urkovitch
donc qui fait de la flûte électronique
bon on va recevoir
un mail donc voilà c'est normal c'est le
relation aussi voilà bah moi je l'aurais
jamais Vladimir urkovitch parce que je
le connais pas mais j'aurais adoré la
voir mais voilà fait de la fuite
électronique il peut se la mettre où je
pense
donc les chaînes info on nous aussi
parler c'était vraiment l'info du jour
regardez cette nouvelle séquence
polémique dans l'émission Touche pas à
mon poste des policiers se présentant
comme membre de la bravème ont été
invités par Cyril Hanouna dans son
émission sur la chaîne C8 trois hommes
et une femme en cagoulé avec une capuche
noire sur la tête et la voix modifiée
certains ont affirmé qu'ils étaient de
la brave et pourtant ce matin l'AFP
continue à affirmer que selon des
sources concordantes aucun mais en
réalité membre de la brave la préfecture
donc assure que d'après les éléments
dont elle dispose les individus en
question n'en font pas partie un
signalement a été effectué auprès de la
procureur de la République alors
Jean-Marc Moroni donc oui il a dit bon
il a des vérité parce que il a eu mes
équipes les autres bon ils ont eu
personne donc voilà donc ils ont fait
leur petit truc et après il y a les
génies du putaclic libération alors là
c'est plus qu'un Kamoulox Cyril Hanouna
accusé d'avoir infilté de faux agents de
la braven dans TP la préfecture de
police saisit la justice
et là il débute son article en écrivant
que le magicien de neuf fait sortir de
faux agents de la braveheme de son
chapeau le show est assuré et promis de
durée donc le mec a pas vu l'émission
alors comment il s'appelle ce gugusse
comment il s'appelle ce guguste à
trouvez-moi son nom si je vais donner
badge c'est pas comment il s'appelle
j'ai vu que je devrais Tristan Berthelot
je croyais que c'était un nom de lycée
ça bon et marcelone
des policiers pas si brave est lié à
l'extrême droite il croit que je vais
demander la carte d'électeurs les mecs
qui sont complètement fous non on prend
des mecs ils étaient cagoulés et puis on
leur demande leur avis sur un truc et
sur les manifestations au moins on avait
des gens sur le terrain et je peux vous
dire que témoignage il était très fort
ah il y avait Télérama aussi les
donneurs de leçons jusqu'où ira
l'animateur de C8 Lucas armati je crois
que c'est une marque de vêtements ça
tient vos agents de la braven shiny
jusqu'où ira l'animateur de C8 c'est pas
des faux agents de la bras même il y en
avait un agent il y avait des mecs qui
étaient sur le terrain donc forcément
aussi ils sont à côté de la plaque 20
minutes tiens 20 minutes je vais même
pas que ça existait encore tiens 20
minutes
des faux agents de la bravène des séries
Hanouna la préfecture de police ou une
enquête ça va pure média au moins ils
ont posé la question ouais ça va voilà
ils ont dit les voilà et on sort 40 le
lendemain dimanche 2 avril là tous les
summer était de sortie bah là il y a un
mec qui leur a mis un seum énorme
c'est le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin et là il a sifflé la fin de la
police
à la télévision
non non
réserve et donc il faut que
l'administration les autorise à parler
ce que nous faisons d'ailleurs au
plateau avis des policiers des gendarmes
tous les jours les autorise évidemment à
parler je trouve ça bien que Monsieur
Luna invite comme d'autres des policiers
des gendarmes donc j'ai proposé que
Monsieur le Préfet de police qui est le
chef de ces policiers à Paris notamment
de la brave puisse être invité sur le
plateau de Monsieur Hanouna lundi et je
crois qu'il sera merci en tout cas au
milieu intérieur et c'est vrai que c'est
important de parler à tous les Français
et de savoir ce qui se passe sur le
terrain on avait reçu des manifestants
la semaine dernière donc on attend que
la manifestants qui étaient dans un état
voilà très très problématique et c'était
normal que le lendemain on est aussi des
policiers parce que voilà on en veut
donner la parole à tout le monde ici il
y a même France Inter tiens les génies
de France Inter encore là tiens les
donneurs de leçons qui ont supplié
l'arcom de nous sanctionner
je suis pierre comme de sanctuer tous
les jours qui racontent n'importe quoi
tiens c'est un mec Cyril la carrière bah
sa carrière elle va pas être longue
elle va s'arrêter précipitamment donc
voilà bon tous les génies ont parlé tous
ces gugus hein voilà comment je les
appelle les gugusses voilà les tous ces
guignols voilà ils ont rien compris
sachez qu'il y avait bien des que des
policiers il y en a un qui a des bits
avaient été débit de ses fonctions c'est
des gens qui étaient sur le terrain
c'était un vrai témoignage et puis si ça
avait été il est parfois il
réfléchissent pas les mecs si ça avait
été des faux policiers ils auraient dit
que des conneries leur discours ils ont
descendu là mais de leur discours il
était complètement il était complètement
audible il disait que alors on a un qui
est énervé qu'est-ce que tu as pensé de
tout ça après on va faire rentrer
laurent-du-nez quand même le préfet de
police de Paris pour parler de choses
sérieuses et non pas de parler de tous
ces gugusses un qui disent tout et
n'importe quoi et qui d'ailleurs j'ai vu
quelqu'un sur BFM j'ai vu une
journaliste hier aussi qui disait
Laurent Inès il faut pas aller chez
Hanouna et cetera le meuf elle a jamais
vu l'émission écoutez moi je vous dis
voilà ben en tout cas ils en ont vite
rattrape pas et puis on sait même pas
qui c'est je dirais pas qui c'était
violente comment elle s'appelait je sais
pas elle était violente en tout cas
surpris ils sont très violents quand ils
sont derrière leur écran derrière leurs
téléphones et puis dès qu'ils arrivent
devant moi ils sont tous mignons ils
m'ont des gâteaux journal
istes parce que on a vu tout le week-end
et ils ont pas vu ils ont pas vu la
séquence et ils ont ils sont ils ont
tapé alors si ils avaient dit n'importe
quoi ces mecs là qui sont venus cagoulés
que des conneries si ils avaient
descendu la police ils ont expliqué
comment ça se passait on a appris des
trucs nous on a même pas parlé on a même
pas on a même pas été les voir en leur
disant oui mais vous tapez quand même
les gens on les a laissé faire ils ont
expliqué les métiers moi j'ai appris
qu'on y recevais des grenades avec des
selles toute la journée je ne savais pas
on apprend des trucs qui viennent pour
défendre la police et toute
se défoule alors moi je redis vous êtes
des bonhommes messieurs les journalistes
après que Monsieur Gérald Darma est
parlé sauf que comme Monsieur Darmanin a
parlé c'est fini les mecs sont plus de
lumière on les a plus entendu parler
donc c'est quand même bizarre ce métier
de journaliste d'être derrière un écran
de cliquer comme ça tu as que c'est ça
votre travail en fait vérifier les mecs
je regardais moi ce qui m'a choqué le
plus pour finir RTL 18h je suis dans ma
voiture j'entends RTL depuis que je suis
parti c'est plus que c'est une grande
radio RTL attention depuis que je suis
parti ils ont perdu deux points 18h ils
ouvrent le journal en disant Hanouna
machin a fait venir des faux policiers
RTL les mecs
vérifier RTL
franchement alors sérieusement c'est la
diffamation vous allez voir le préfet de
police
rapidement savoir ce qui se passe sur
les manies mais c'est de la diffamation
mais le préfet de police on l'a pas pour
ça on a envie de parler de sujet un peu
plus sérieux
et victime d'un acharnement médiatique
et ne vous trompez pas quand les
journalistes parlent de ça ils ne
trouvent pas ça scandaleux c'est
uniquement pour faire du CLIC et moi ce
que je comprends pas c'est que il y a
des émissions à la télé il y en a eu
plein avec des faux témoignages des fake
news qui ont été propagé même dans des
émissions très sérieuses des JT personne
n'en parle donc là ils veulent
uniquement se faire des cas on aurait
juste été piégé c'était pas notre faute
en vrai mais c'est arrivé plein de fois
dans des gitans
vous allez être des flics et vous allez
vous dire quand ça arrive dans les JT
dans les reportages etc mais ils en font
pas tout un plat ils font pas la une de
l'actualité que ça donc au bout d'un
moment s'ils veulent se faire TPMP qu'il
fasse un hors-série